guilty of murder and manslaughter
together emma tustin and thomas hughes
tortured his son to death in cctv shown
to the jury arthur is so weak he's
barely able to stand the six-year-old
cries as he tries to put his bedding
away he's limping his body covered in
bruises from frequent beatings
after weeks of being starved and
dehydrated his little body is broken
in a few hours he'll have his head
banged by tustin so hard he'll die
arthur a bright happy child who loved
learning and playing football suffered
130 bruises
during weeks of abuse at their home in
sully hull tustin kept recordings of
arthur crying
[Music]
but there was no one to comfort him or
help him as he begged for food
[Music]
for his grandmother it's hard to bear
i think they are
cold
calculating
systematic
torturers
of a defenseless little boy
he was always happy
smiling
loving
caring
um
and he was my daughter's little love
her daughter arthur's mother was in
prison at the time of his death
arthur's father cut ties with the family
when he met tustin
it was the start of the first national
lockdown when arthur and his father
moved in here with emma tustin over the
weeks that followed he was subjected to
sustained cruelty near constant physical
and psychological abuse and it was
largely hidden from public view in fact
some neighbours have told us they didn't
even know arthur was living here
there are now messages of love at the
house where he suffered and questions
for social services who were contacted
by family about this bruise but visited
and saw no other injuries so took no
action
this terrible tragedy has had a shocking
impact on arthur's family and across the
whole community
the tragic loss of a young boy in such
terrible circumstances is dreadful
we send our heartfelt condolences to
everybody affected
the circumstances around the death will
be now subject of independent review
the local child safeguarding practice
review
and clearly it would be inappropriate
for the partnership
to comment ahead of the findings of this
review
police also visited arthur two months
before his death but reported he
appeared safe and well
the professionals and wider family
members that should have been involved
in arthur's life weren't they weren't
around so they weren't there to spot the
signs i do think lockdown created the
perfect set of circumstances for that
abuse to go unnoticed
a child safeguarding review will examine
what more could have been done to save
arthur
a little boy tortured and killed at home
where he should have been safe becky
johnson sky news zolly hull